a lot of people call this the dr seuss
house first of all nobody asked dr seuss
for permission to do that
they refer to that because of some of
the
ideas that dr seuss said
i think he was a genius and i think he
did a lot of good for the world
i try and write poetry and i kind of
think of this as a poem to the sky
[Music]
i am philip paul widener i'm the owner
and builder of goose creek tower i went
to mit and i'm kind of a frustrated
architect so i like building
i just designed it out of my head we
didn't have blueprints we drew it out on
cardboard plywood just as we were going
what i'm going to end up doing
eventually is put some hooks there and
hang pots and pans off them because this
is the kitchen i started to build a
40x40 scribe log cabin and i realized i
could put pillars on top and put another
house on top of a house
and i just kept going we got to 185 feet
and we stopped because um 200 feet is
federal air space
now i just have to finish it out
this is pretty much the last real stairs
there are multiple levels in there and
i've tried to count them and it's just
impossible it depends how you count
stories
i wanted to be able to
see and that's the reason i went up you
can actually see for
at least 300 miles and of course
when the northern lights are out
you can really see
i hope that goose creek tower will
inspire other people to do worthwhile
things not just in building but whatever
they do with their life
and every time i go up there it's a
different experience
kind of give you a sense of the enormity
of the universe
[Music]
a nest is a place where you have a sense
of protection and strength
it's like an earth temple or a nature
temple
the wood is following a pattern but not
one branch is the same
as a nest builder i'm following those
patterns
most of the work is trying to bring out
the best of those shapes with each other
[Music]
i'm jason fan and i'm a nest builder
i started building nests as a child the
nest building was really
an intuitive process of just
gathering branches and and building
forts originally and
the nest grew and got bigger and more
elaborate
now some of the nests are as big as a
hundred thousand pounds of wood
the hardest part of building the nest is
really gathering all of the wood
i use a chainsaw to cut wood i use a
machete to
cut off all the excess leaves and from
there i really assess you know what kind
of shapes i have what kind of material i
have to work with
the construction process of the nest
first is creating the foundation and the
infrastructure
and then i follow those larger
sculptural shapes that i bolt together
with smaller material that i can weave
in and around
i use every part of the tree the trunk
of the tree all the way down to the very
smallest twig and branch of the tree
i've gotten to where i'm used to
building them on flatbed trailers and
moving them around and in many cases i'm
transporting them across the country
because the nests are quite heavy i use
cranes and forklifts and different kinds
of equipment
this is all eucalyptus there's over 75
different species of eucalyptus on this
property i've built around 50 nests all
over the country and now primarily i
build the nests with kids within an
educational setting
as an educator like it's really
important to
work with kids and help them
realize that they have the ability to
shape and create an environment i'm
going to show you how we can integrate
those branches into the spiral
i love
getting kids out into nature interacting
with nature and the nest is actually
very much a collaboration with nature
i know i've done a good job when it
looks like the nest is something that
could almost have grown out of the
ground
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
i live in palo alto california and it's
a bizarre thing i think for people here
to build things physical things most
folks are doing.coms
it's kind of neverland in palo alto and
so anything is possible my name is chris
robinson and for four or five years i've
been working on building the tsunami
ball it's designed to survive an inland
tsunami
[Music]
march 2011
there was an earthquake off the shore of
sendai in japan which caused a tsunami
to basically smash against
the eastern seaboard when the tsunami
happened i was at this incubator in
mountain view and i was watching live
footage of people trying to escape and
the entire office just starts discussing
how they would fix that or solve that
and i decided then well you could very
simply just put them in like a ping-pong
ball right like a sphere is a very
strong shape and so you could usher your
family into and they would float around
and they would be safe
and so i started just kind of modifying
the designs and at some point i just
extruded the shape a bit and now it's a
capsule
almost everything i'm doing here is
brand new to me i made mistakes from day
one and this was this piece that i
custom designed to be super strong and
it's massively thick right it's four
inches thick but yeah it twisted and
just snapped in half
so this is what happened when the boat
fell on me you just hope that you
survived the mistakes long enough so
that you can make progress
and then you you can
learn
[Music]
the idea is that we'll have electric
motors
solar panels on the outside and
batteries and you'll be able to navigate
from the boat so it's not going to be a
speed boat but you'd be able to navigate
your way wherever you need to go back to
shore or help somebody else that needs
help
so we kind of share the same ideas about
how to evaluate someone's project and
it's usually based on intelligence or
money time and on those three things
this is the dumbest project you could
ever do
and so i just think of it as an
adventure i'm excited every day that i'm
out here working on it the importance is
just
just building it
[Music]
the most recognizable thing in the sky
is obviously the silhouette of the
spitfire she's just a beautiful lady i'm
sure a lot of men would actually like to
marry her
i'm sure their wives wouldn't agree
there's 396 parts in a spitfire seat
how do i know that i built it
[Music]
this is martin phillips my name is
martin phillips and i'm sitting next to
my spitfire rr232 which i'm the proud
owner of
martin is obsessed with spitfires
the big bombers join in pounding the
shoreline
in the darkest days of world war ii
spitfires filled the sky above england
they are an icon like freedom on wings
british kids make models of them
but martin took his spitfire devotion to
a whole other level
for his 40th birthday
martin's friends gave him a single
spitfire rivet
when i was presented with this rivet the
challenge was to go and build myself a
spitfire so on the spur of the moment
not thinking i said right i'll go out on
the monday morning and i will build a
spitfire i never thought that over a
period of 14 years that i'd probably
wear three cars out with mileage along
the journey to provide all the parts
that you now see today
it's the fuel tanks they came from
norway and sweden some of the other
parts came from russia
some of the parts came from israel some
of the other parts came from holland
came from france
one of the wings was offered to us
through a lost property department
and another wing came through a little
guy coming into work said i've got a
spitfire wing in my garden
the man hours that go into a project
like this don't underestimate it they
are terrific and i know the blood sweat
and tears that went into that
after 14 years i know the question
you're going to ask me
do you fly it
sadly not
i am learning to fly and i hope one day
to fly it but greater guys than me flyer
my name's matt jones i'm a spitfire
pilot
the modern airliners fly 85 percent the
speed of sound they got spitfires flying
at 96 97
speed of sound
you don't get in a spitfire you strap it
on and it becomes a part of you
because the airplane means so much to so
many people there are a lot of people
who have gone down martin's path and
started thinking they want to build a
spitfire
but i've never met anyone else who's
completed it
he dedicated his life to finding the
parts he needed to get this aeroplane
flying again
i went through these 14 years had
heartache and bits didn't fit
just putting it together and finishing
it and the providence and the journey
the journey i went on you know tears
even today i cry when it runs it's just
been amazing absolutely amazing
you